you
[Laughter]
it's a beautiful day to be alive
[__] you dare enter this [__]
house on the Lord's Day
some people got time to [__] around we
don't [__] around here you understand me
it's the [__] Lord's day he want to
[__] around go [__] around with your
little [__] friends at Starbucks and
talk about your faith [__] hopes and
dreams and all March it's uncle Joey
time [__] and that's not your bad
[__] uncle Joey here on the
Lord's Day in other words uncle Joey
esta aqui you follow me it's a beautiful
day to be alive you got no [__]
excuses get up off your ass you got a
whole new week coming last week was last
week this week is this week you got
plans and admirations you understand me
aspirations I'm very sorry about that
sometimes I [__] up the word but who
gives a [__] you know what I'm saying
[__] it's August 20th four months
away from the [__] holidays and
you're still sitting there waiting for
[__] ITT Institute the coiler they
ain't gonna call [__] it's all on
you you have to do your twenty two
push-ups you're gonna write your goals
and most importantly you've got to smoke
this [__] her but that's why because
it opens up the [__] mental passages
in your brain and it always gives you
the answer you understand me you think I
got here because I'm smarter than you
[__] no I got here because the reefer
gave me the answer we got some big 26
left it's been killing us all week out
of [__] Northern California these
guys are geniuses you might have seen
their weed on [__] Vice land geniuses
these young kids you understand me horse
with no name this [__] I don't even know
what's in there all I know is every time
I [__] smoke it the answers come to
me if I went on Jeopardy I would [__]
them up you understand me
thank you for watching the Joe Rogan
podcast we had a good time I know we're
talking about taking shits but you know
me I'm no Phi Beta cap and funny it's
funny for you [__] huh I like
mind a thought-provoking comedy go [__]
yourself
if it makes you laugh and brains your
day it's [__] funny to rescue - too
[__] uptight you still waiting for
Hillary to make a comeback go shoot
yourself you understand me we're here
with queer and it's all over but the
shouting your [__] are worried
about racism the [__] that bothers me
the most is classism I live in Studio
City with these [__] Lutz's that you
know but anyway who gives a [__] about
the negative it's all about love if
you've got love in your life hey I got
listen I got three Jews in my life with
bad wiring when you've got a Jew with
bad wiring that's all you need you got a
friend forever some people have smart
intelligent friends
give me a dumb [__] with heart and I'll
take over a [__] County like I did
all my [__] life okay so that's it
and that's that let me tell you what's
crack-a-lackin' tonight we got a podcast
at 8 o'clock the church what's happening
now could be 6 it could be 7 who gives a
[__] just beat it we got a tremendous
podcast on Tuesday night at 8 o'clock
maybe 9 o'clock and Ontario I feel bad
for you this weekend not Ontario Canada
that used to be my spot when I sneak
into [__] Canada through Buffalo I go
to Ontario to the bus station and take
it up to Toronto and all points [__]
north you don't say
the proper of death this side broke
[__] go to this side here man
and Ontario improv
Friday Saturday and Thursday night me I
can care less about McGregor I could
care less about Mayweather I don't give
a [__] who fights I don't give a [__]
who wins because there's gonna be three
fights anyway they're gonna get the most
out of this and that's just another scam
on the American public me uncle Joey I'd
rather watch the [__] monsters you
understand me and you asked why Joey why
because listen when I used to [__]
take bets on the phone the unanimous
decision always [__] loses when you
talk to people all I got to do is take
up go up to 100 people ask them who's
gonna win but against them
that's how you win in sports you [__]
dummies every once in a while you get it
but the general public will give you the
answer it's that easy see my [__]
pedophile whatever they call this [__]
periscope is not about smoking reefer
haha Sandy's you've learned something on
the Lord's Day this right here this is
the week that killed Jerry Lewis you
understand me for years he was given the
kid like let's say a kid didn't make a
lot of money on the telethon he came out
and they put him play the drums right in
the [__] Jerry would give him a weed and
shoot him in the head not today Jerry
smoke this weed and what happened he's
gone through girl I mean Jerry here's to
you like I said beside that listen
whatever happened last week last week
all right at my last week your
girlfriend dumped you yeah your boss
told you you're a [__] idiot listen
whatever who gives a [__] this is the
week you make a comeback you make a
comeback like [__] herpes you do your
push-ups you write your goals and you
tell these [__] you ain't
stopping till you hit the top you
understand me there's a rap song must it
must be the music and there's a part in
the rap when he goes ever since I was a
baby boy my mother gave me a brand new
toy two turntables and a mic and I
learned
how to blow something I've acted me but
I knew someday I would rock the nation
you know how important those words are
that he knew someday he would rock the
nation I want you to think about those
words because that's what you're about
to do with what we are about to do
anyway let me smoke this riff I'm little
roll around one of my buddies for a
little while maybe lift some weights and
then I come back I got the family for
the afternoon and then tonight I got a
[__] podcast I was already at [__]
the coffee shop right for two hours I
had my little eggs my little green tea
and now I'm ready for the day but let's
smoke some of this [__] debt that's
it when that's that I'll see you
[__] tonight the Church of
what's happened now you know I love you
[__] with all my heart member
it's a whole new week whatever happened
last week you can't change it's what's
gonna happen this week that you're gonna
[__] control forget to change stay
black
it's the Lord's Day uncle Joey love is
you're sorry about the [__] Sun but
it's better than sitting in the darkness
and I'm saying